und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
vielleicht war es die Erleichterung
darüber dass es endlich vorbei war dass
sie so aufgekratzt wirkten schon der
Kanzler hatte zwischendurch demonstrativ
gute Laune verbreitet und das gleiche
Horn stießen dann auch die drei
Parteivorsitzenden bei ihrem abendlichen
Auftritt vor der Hauptstadtpresse eine
schlaflose Nacht 30 Stunden
Verhandlungen lagen hinter ihnen aber
man sei bester Stimmung nach dem Motto
war doch gut dass wir mal wieder
ausführlich miteinander geredet haben in
Berliner politischer Gong nennt man das
der Sache einen Spin geben auf gut
deutsch wenn was nicht gut gelaufen ist
muss man es wenigstens gut aussehen
lassen
Patricia Wiedemeier berichtet
heute morgen Tag 3 der
Koalitionsgespräche Grüne und SPD
versuchen gute Laune zu verbreiten
erfolgreich und gut wünsche Ihnen
schönen Tag
ganz gut doch so gut lief es dann wohl
doch nicht wieder endloses warten vor
dem Kanzleramt während drinnen
verhandelt wurde einen ganzen Tag lang
selten gab es so lange
Koalitionsgespräche erst am späten
Nachmittag dann äußerte sich ein
überraschend gut gelaunter Kanzler der
die Runde verlassen hatte den Besuch des
kenianischen Präsidenten konnte er nicht
verschieben ein großes Gesamtwerk das
die Mühe gelohnt habe für die
Modernisierung des Landes kündigt er an
ohne Details zu nehmen hier wird es
sogar sehr sehr gute Ergebnisse geben
und Sie werden ein bisschen überrascht
sein was da so alles drin ist weil sie
in den Erörterung worüber wir reden an
einigen Stellen völlig falsch liegen
wenn ich das auf die Gesamtheit der
deutschen Medienlandschaft bezogen
sondern Topfschlagen hat nicht immer
funktioniert da war nix unter dem Topf
wo sie drauf geklopft haben was genau er
damit meinte welche Themen da noch so
unter dem Topf lagen die Auflösung ließ
auf sich warten eine Partei habe das
schon geschnürte Gesamtwerk wieder
aufgeschnürt hieß es eine für kurz nach
18 Uhr angekündigte Pressekonferenz
wurde verschoben es wurde gestritten
heftig diskutiert für die Opposition
dauerte es viel zu lange wir haben ganz
offensichtlich in Deutschland eine
Regierungskrise die Bundesregierung
eignet sich eignet sich in den
wesentlichen Fragen der deutschen
Politik nicht mehr die Kritik sie kam
dann doch vielleicht etwas zu früh vor
zwei Stunden dann die lange sehnte
Einigung man habe sich bewusst viel Zeit
genommen Durchbrüche erzielt
Paradigmenwechsel geschaffen die das
Land verändern würden das sind große
weitgehende Beschlüsse zu Modernisierung
des Landes die wir getroffen haben wir
legen eine gute Grundlage dafür dass
Deutschland ein starkes erfolgreiches
Land bleibt dass die Arbeitsplätze die
Infrastruktur der Zukunft auch
geschaffen werden vereinbart hat die
Ampel unter anderem dass die Lkw-Maut
erhöht wird 80 Prozent von dem was
reinkommt soll in den Ausbau der Bahn
fließen nachgeben mussten die Grünen
beim Thema planungsbeschleunigung diese
soll nun auch für eine begrenzte Anzahl
an Autobahnen gelten allerdings unter
einer Bedingung wir haben uns
gleichzeitig darauf geeinigt dass wir in
Zukunft verpflichtend beim Neubau von
Autobahnen die Solar Möglichkeiten der
Solarenergie am Rand nutzen werden das
heißt wir starten eine riesige
solar-ausbau Offensive verbinden
Klimaschutz mit Straßenbau heftige
Kritik der Grünen gab es im Vorfeld
daran dass der Verkehrsbereich zu wenig
für den Klimaschutz Beitrage vereinbart
wurde nun das andere Sektoren andere
Bereiche kompensieren können hier hat
sich die FDP durchgesetzt bei der
wärmewende beim heizungswechsel sagt
Finanzminister Lindner dafür
Unterstützung und finanzielle Hilfen zu
es wird keine Austauschpflicht geben für
bestehende Heizungen sondern lediglich
Vorgaben für neu eingebaute Heizungen
und wir werden bei bestimmten Alters-
und Einkommensgruppen automatisch auch
darauf achten dass die Vorgaben nicht
belastend oder bindend sind und
ausreichende übergangszeiträume werden
wir ebenfalls schaffen der Ton sei
ruppig gewesen Kompromisse hart erkämpft
worden aber wenn solche Ergebnisse
herauskommen dann könne er jeden Monat
drei Tage in Klausur gehen so FDP-Chef
Lindner
der Abend in Berlin er ging dann ganz
persönlich und feierlich zu Ende
Zapfenstreich für die frühere
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht die im Januar zurückgetreten
war Aufbruch und Abschied manchmal
liegen sie in der Politik eben ganz nah
beieinander
und der SPD-Chef Lars klingen weil es
uns zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
klingenball
heute und gestern immer wieder die
Spannung des Publikums erhöht indem er
versprach es werde sehr sehr sehr sehr
gute Ergebnisse geben aber warum hat das
denn so sehr sehr lange gedauert
wir hatten vieles zu klären in der
Koalition im letzten Jahr haben wir uns
ja darauf konzentriert dass wir das Land
gut durch die Krise durchbringen die
Energiekrise die Frage ob Energie
bezahlbar bleibt drei große
entlastungspakete die Gas- und
strompreisbremse das war die Agenda im
letzten Jahr aber jetzt wollen wir den
Schritt nach vorne machen große
strukturelle Veränderungen anschieben
die Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen die großen
Infrastrukturprojekte voranbringen damit
Deutschland ein starkes Land bleibt und
das hat jetzt einfach zweieinhalb Tage
gedauert um dort vieles zu klären also
hat man eigentlich zu viel auf den Tisch
gelegt hätte man das da nicht schon
vorher mal abarbeiten können in Meseberg
zum Beispiel wäre doch auch Gelegenheit
gewesen sich auseinanderzusetzen und
Konflikte zu lösen
wir haben uns viel vorgenommen dieser
Koalition jetzt waren ja die Parteien
die Fraktion mit am Tisch der
Koalitionsausschuss ist ein Gremium der
Parteien insofern haben wir auch über
das Regierungshandeln hinausgedacht aber
natürlich gab es auch Projekte der
Regierung beispielsweise wenn es um die
wärmewende geht und die Frage wie machen
wir das jetzt eigentlich mit den
Heizungen und da haben wir schon klar
festgehalten dass wir dafür sorgen
wollen dass es keine Unsicherheit gibt
in der wärmewende dass das auch
bezahlbar bleibt und dass niemand
unsicher sein muss in diesem Land aber
noch mal das ist ein großes
modernisierungspaket für das Land das
wird das Land über die nächsten
Jahrzehnte verändern das was wir auf den
Weg gebracht haben und dann kann es auch
mal zweieinhalb Tage dauern aber Herr
klingen bei 30 Stunden und eine ganze
Nacht durch das ist ja nicht normal also
das kann man ja auch den Publikum nicht
erzählen dass es halt ein bisschen
gedauert hat weil war halt so viel zu
besprechen
also ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
es schneller geht aber das ist die erste
Regierung mit drei Parteien und wissen
Sie wir tragen schon ein bisschen noch
die großen gesellschaftlichen Konflikte
aus die es gibt wenn es zum Beispiel um
die Frage geht wie bringen wir eine
starke Industriepolitik mit der Frage
von Ökologie und Umweltschutz zusammen
wie machen wir das eigentlich mit den
großen Infrastrukturprojekten wenn wir
wollen dass die Schienen schneller
gebaut werden dass die Straßen schneller
gebaut werden dass die erneuerbaren
Energien schneller ausgebaut werden das
kann man in sonntags reden immer sagen
aber jetzt ging es sehr konkret darum zu
sagen wie kriegen wir das die nächsten
Jahre hin also wie kriegen wir den Turbo
jetzt auch rein die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit die wir beim Ausbau der
LG Terminals gezeigt haben und noch mal
wenn am Ende steht dass wir Deutschland
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten maßgeblich
verändern mit diesem Beschlüssen dann
bin ich auch bereit mich mal zweieinhalb
Tage am Tisch zu setzen naja wenn man
sich das jetzt anguckt also auch Herr
Lindner hat ja bahnbrechenden
Paradigmenwechsel dann heute vorhin
davon gesprochen
bei dem Klimaschutz würden werden die
Sektoren Ziele aufgegeben es gibt 14 4
autobahnprojekte beim Gasheizung gibt's
eigentlich eine Tür offen dafür dass man
es dann doch nicht so schnell machen
muss die haben Sie denn die Grünen dazu
gebracht den zuzustimmen hat die FDP mit
Koalitionsbruch gedroht
nein das waren konstruktive Gespräche
wir sind uns der großen Aufgaben und der
Verantwortung die wir haben bewusst und
wenn sie da reingucken dann sieht man
dass wir alle ein gemeinsames Interesse
haben den Klimaschutz voranzubringen die
Infrastrukturprojekte auszubauen und
wirklich auch die Planungs- und
genehmigungszeiten drastisch zu
verkürzen und dafür zu sorgen dass der
Turbo eingelegt wird und das sind Dinge
die alle drei Koalitionspartner zusammen
vertreten und die dafür sorgen werden
dass die Arbeitsplätze der Zukunft des
Wachstum der Zukunft hier in Deutschland
stattfindet aber wo ist denn da jetzt
der große Turbo ich habe ihn noch nicht
entdecken können helfen sie mir
also der Turbo ist beispielsweise dort
wo Planungs und Genehmigungsverfahren
massiv beschleunigt werden wo wir bei
der Schiene bei der Straße beim Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren beim Ausbau der Netze
bei der Frage auch wie wenden wir
Naturschutzrecht an wenn es
beispielsweise im Ausgleichsflächen geht
ein riesiges Problem das waren ganz
vielen Stellen weil das die Bremse das
Ausgleichsflächen gefunden werden
mussten hier haben wir jetzt ein
Paradigmenwechsel werden dafür sorgen
dass zusammenhängende Flächen geschaffen
werden können das ist um finanzielle
Ausgleiche geht alles das trägt dazu bei
dass wirklich viele Dinge in Zukunft
schneller umgesetzt werden können und
wir wissen doch wir haben uns doch alle
in den letzten Jahren immer beschwert
darüber dass die Windkraftanlage so
lange gedauert hat die
futtervoltaikanlage der Ausbau der
Straße und der Schiene und alles das
wird jetzt künftig schneller gehen viele
auszubauen braucht es auch Geld da soll
jetzt eine Erhöhung der Lkw-Maut helfen
aber eben auch wohl nur die Erhöhung und
davon 80%, also wenn die ganze Lkw-Maut
ungefähr 8 Milliarden im Jahr bringt
oder 7 Milliarden reicht das dann um die
Schienennetz der Deutschen Bahn
auszubauen die nennt da viel höhere
Zahlen die sie braucht
aber wir haben auch andere Maßnahmen
beschrieben in diesem Papier zum
Beispiel der Klima und
transformationsfonds der ja auch helfen
wird dass wir investieren beispielsweise
wenn es jetzt darum geht Förderprogramme
auf den Weg zu bringen damit die
wärmewende gelingt also wir nehmen Geld
für den Klimaschutz in die Hand wir
beschleunigen die Verfahren und am Ende
sind das gute Entscheidung für unser
Land und wenn ich mir das ansehe was sie
jetzt beschlossen haben also es gibt ja
auch alles noch recht frisch hier auf
dem Tisch zu der Sanierung von Heizungen
dann hat man jetzt 30 Stunden lang so
viel gestritten dass am Ende nicht mehr
die Zeit war um noch mal konkret zu
sagen wie denn da die sozialen
Entlastungen stattfinden sollen sondern
das wird jetzt erst noch ausgearbeitet
ja aber da sage ich Ihnen das ist
Aufgabe der Regierung genau das jetzt zu
machen wir haben als Parteien und
Koalitionsausschuss gesagt das ist diese
wärmewende nur geben wird wenn soziale
Härten abgefährt abgefedert werden wenn
genau drauf geachtet wird wie die
Menschen mitgenommen werden wie
Unsicherheiten abgebaut werden das haben
wir jetzt festgelegt als Parteien und
das wird die Regierung jetzt umsetzen
stand aber so auch schon in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag
aber jetzt geht es um die konkrete
Gesetzgebung und da haben die drei
Parteien die diese Regierung führen die
diese Regierung stellen jetzt eine klare
Marschrichtung auch mitgegeben und wird
man jetzt künftig freundlicher
miteinander umgehen haben Sie das Gefühl
das hat jetzt zu einer großen Befriedung
gesorgt diese marathon-sitzung
wissen Sie es ist ja kein Geheimnis das
ist in den letzten Wochen doch das ein
oder andere Mal ruppig war natürlich
haben wir auch darüber geredet das ist
wichtig dass man in einer Koalition noch
über diese Dinge spricht und wenn es
nach mir geht können wir das gerne in
den nächsten Wochen lassen die Menschen
haben hohe Erwartung wir haben hohe
Aufgaben mit dieser Regierung zu
erledigen wir werden das in einem riesen
Tempo machen müssen und dafür brauchen
wir weniger Streit mehr Konstruktivität
und das habe ich die letzten zweieinhalb
Tage erlebt das ist so wie es in den
letzten 200 Tagen war kannst jetzt gerne
weitergehen dann werden wir wirklich das
Land verändern aber mit mehr schlafen
nämlich an Herr kling weil danke Ihnen
für das Gespräch
mehr schlafe schön vielen Dank alles
Gute
haben wir vor einer halben Stunde
geführt und nachher im heute journal
Update gibt es dann einen Interview zur
Perspektive der FDP mit deren
Fraktionschef Christian
dass das Regierung zu einer Menge Streit
führen kann ist offensichtlich vor allem
wenn sehr unterschiedliche Parteien
unter einen Hut gebracht werden müssen
aber auch in der Opposition kann man
sich offenkundig zerlegen die Fraktion
der Linken ist zerrissen was viel aber
nicht nur mit ihrem Mitglied Sahra
Wagenknecht zu tun hat die damit droht
eine neue Partei zu gründen das würde
vielleicht sogar befriedigend wirken
aber der Linken könnte damit der
Fraktionsstatus abhanden kommen Andreas
vielleicht kommt die Lösung für die
Krise der Linkspartei aus Leipzig mit
Ice 16.06 Ankunft 7 Uhr 29 Sören
Pellmann hat das bisher einzige
Direktmandat seiner Partei außerhalb
Berlins errungen und ihr so den
Fraktionsstatus gerettet an diesem
Morgen soll Pellmann verhindern dass die
Linke ihn wieder verspielt im Gepäck ein
Antrag des Kreisverbands Leipzig der
davor warnt das ist DIE LINKE bald nicht
mehr geben werde zur ersten
Fraktionssitzung nach dem Wagenknecht
Roms kommt Unmut nach Berlin deswegen
ist ja auch die Idee entstanden
aufzubegehren und der Basis mehr Stimme
zu geben der ruft nach einem
Sonderparteitag ist ja der erste
Ausdruck der ruft danach in den Dialog
zu treten der wartenknecht Roms
schüttelt die Partei durch er wird vor
zehn Tagen ausgelöst als die bekannteste
Linke im zdfund gibt die Gründung einer
eigenen Partei zu erwägen
wer in die Politik gegangen ist will ja
doch etwas verändern etwas Positives
bewirken und wir merken eben so wie die
Linke sich aktuell entwickelt ist das ja
immer weniger möglich kann wer die Linke
nicht links findet noch Teil von ihr
sein die Parteiführung will Wagenknecht
rausschmeißen die Fraktionsführung will
wartenknecht einbinden dann geh doch
endlich wird sie genauso oft wie wenn du
gehst gehe ich mit heute in der Fraktion
fehlen entschuldigt
Wagenknecht aber ohne hin nehmen sich
wagenknechtsgegner einmal mehr deren
Fürsprecher vor einmal mehr Partei gegen
Fraktion ich bin für eine Verjüngung
also für eine Änderung in der Fraktion
speziell jenseits der bisherigen
Blockbildungen gemeint ist nicht nur
aber vor allem
langzeitfraktionschef Dietmar Bartsch
was sagen sie denn zu den
Rücktrittsforderungen von Herrn der
nächste bitte was den Streit um
Wagenknecht und Ihre Freunde für die
Partei so bedrohlich macht mit ihren 39
Abgeordneten kann die Linke im Bundestag
nur mit Ach und Krach eine Fraktion
bilden falls Wagenknecht geht und ihr
drei Abgeordnete Folgen wäre die Linke
keine Fraktion mehr sondern eine Gruppe
mit weniger Geld weniger Redezeit
weniger posten aber es dürften sogar
mehr als 4 werden also es gibt ja wie
gesagt sehr viele Diskussionen und
auch Interesse ganz klar der
zeitumwagenknecht ist gleich der Streit
um die Ukraine die Kritik an
wagenknechtsallianzen etwa von Bodo
Ramelow regt etwa die Leipziger auf
konkret meine ich wenn der Parteitag
noch mal wie im Erfurt ja
festgeschrieben Waffenlieferungen die
Ukraine ausschließt dass eine
stellvertretende Parteivorsitzende oder
eigentlich ganz unbekanntes Mitglied aus
Thüringen genau das Gegenteil behauptet
für einen Sonderparteitag über
Positionen und Personal wollen die
Leipziger jetzt Unterschriften sammeln
aus Berlin bringt Sören Pellmann keine
große Hoffnung mit
und jetzt macht erstmal ein zweiter mit
anderen Nachrichten des Tages auch nach
dem Warnstreiktag gestern gibt es im
Tarifkonflikt des öffentlichen Dienstes
offenbar noch keinen Durchbruch die
aktuelle Verhandlungsrunde der
Tarifparteien Verdi und Beamtenbund
sowie Bund und Kommunen soll
voraussichtlich bis morgen dauern nach
den Arbeitsniederlegungen ist der
Verkehr schnell wieder angelaufen die
Bahn nahm den blasenmäßigen Zugverkehr
wieder auf und ebenso die Flughäfen
ihren Betrieb
in Frankreich ist die rentnerreform zwar
beschlossen trotzdem gab es heute
inzwischen den Zehnten landesweiten
Protesttag die gewerkschaften rufen dazu
auf Streiks und Kundgebungen weiter
vorzusetzen dabei richtet sich der Unmut
zunehmend gegen die Regierung im
Allgemeinen die über Wochen friedlichen
Proteste wurden zuletzt wie heute hier
in Paris von massiver Gewalt und
Auseinandersetzungen überschattet die
Polizei ist mit einem Großaufgebot auf
den Straßen
ab sofort werden Schufa-Daten nach einer
Privatinsolvenz nur noch sechs Monate
gespeichert bisher waren es drei Jahre
die Verkürzung der Speicherdauer
geschieht unter dem Druck laufen der
Gerichtsverfahren laut Schufa
profitieren davon rund 250.000
Betroffene so solle Klarheit und
Sicherheit für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher geschaffen werden erklärte
Vorstandsmitglied Ole Schröder
die EU-Staaten wollen weiter große
Mengen Gas einsparen um die Speicher für
den nächsten Winter zu füllen die
Energieminister der Mitgliedstaaten
verständigten sich in Brüssel darauf
dazu den Gas Notfallplan der diese Woche
ausläuft um ein Jahr zu verlängern
demnach sollen die EU-Staaten ihren
Gasverbrauch weiter freiwillig um 15%
reduzieren gegenüber dem
Durchschnittsverbrauch des Zeitraumes
von april 2017 bis März 2022
bei einem Brand in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Mexiko nahe der
US-Grenze sind mindestens 39 Migranten
ums Leben gekommen in weiteren 29
Menschen wurden bei dem Feuer verletzt
teilte die mexikanische
Einwanderungsbehörde mit aus Protest
gegen eine drohende Abschiebung zündeten
Migranten offenbar Matratzen an und das
Feuer sei dann außer Kontrolle geraten
so der mexikanische Präsident Lopez
oprador
zu den deprimierenden Terminen jedes
Jahres gehört die Veröffentlichung des
Jahresberichts von Amnesty International
im geballter Form bekommt man da
wiederkehrend einen Eindruck davon was
der Mensch den Menschen so alles antut
an Unterdrückung Grausamkeit und
Verachtung und das quer über den Globus
die international sind allein seit
Beginn der Proteste im September dort
22.000 Menschen festgenommen worden
viele sind in Gefängnissen und
Folterkellern verschwunden Festnahmen
und Schauprozesse sind eh fester
Bestandteil des iranischen Regimes dass
seine Kritiker auch im Ausland verfolgt
und verschleppt einen solchen Fall
beschreiben Kamera
sie kommt in Begleitung eines
personenschützers er soll es schon macht
aus Angst sie ist die Tochter des
deutsch-iranischen Regimekritikers Jump
she der Short macht der auf einer Reise
entführt wurde in den Iran dort droht
ihm jetzt die Hinrichtung
ich weiß nicht wie es meinem Vater geht
ich weiß noch nicht mal ob er überhaupt
noch lebt er ist seit 950 Tagen in den
isolations- und Einzelhaft niemand kommt
an ihn ran ich darf nicht mit ihm
telefonieren wir wissen nichts von ihm
seit all dieser Zeit ich bin jetzt nach
Berlin gekommen damit ich endlich mit
den Menschen reden kann die mein Vater
retten können die mein Vater aus dieser
Hölle rausholen können also trifft sich
mit Menschenrechtsgruppen und
AktivistInnen die Proteste in Iran haben
auch ein Schlaglicht auf das Schicksal
ihres Vaters geworfen
Bilder aus glücklichen Tagen in
Deutschland lebte die Familie bevor sie
nach Kalifornien zog Jumps ein
Softwareentwickler war ein scharfer
Kritiker des iranischen Regimes
2020 auf einer Reise nach Indien wird er
bei einem Stopp in Dubai verschleppt
nach Tera das Regime wirft ihm einen
Anschlag auf eine Moschee vor und führt
ihn im Staatsfernsehen vor ein
schau-prozess sagen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen wir fordern
dass sich um diesen Fall prioritär
gekümmert wird dass der Fall von Gazelle
der Vater johnshiam hat diesen Namen
muss jeder kennen denn wenn jumpshy
Charm hat hingerichtet wird dann haben
wir alle versagt Druck aufbauen das wird
auch auf politische Bühne sie trifft den
CDU-Vorsitzenden und Oppositionsführer
Friedrich Merz er hat die politische
Patenschaft für ihren Vater übernommen
und appelliert an den Iran
von iranischen nehmen Sie das Urteil
gegen Herrn scharmat zurück und lassen
Sie ihn ausreißen ich will allerdings
hinzufügen wenn das noch länger dauert
werde ich mich auch dafür einsetzen dass
es verschärfte Reaktionen gibt auch
Sanktionen gibt ich bin auch der
Auffassung dass die deutsche Wirtschaft
diesem Treiben nicht unbegrenzte
zuschauen darf
sitzen viele politische Gefangene in
iranischen Gefängnissen allein seit den
Protesten über 20.000
international werden viele gefoltert
politischer und wirtschaftlicher Druck
aus Deutschland Irans wichtigsten
Handelspartner in der EU hilft glaub
doch Gazelle doch bislang mache die
Bundesregierung zu wenig er wurde
entführt nichts ist passiert er wurde
gefoltert und nichts ist passiert er hat
das Todesurteil bekommen und nichts ist
passiert zwei Diplomaten wurden
ausgewiesen aber mein Vater ist immer
noch da mein Vater ist immer noch in
Todesgefahr mein Vater soll immer noch
hingerichtet werden und so kämpft eine
Tochter weiter um das Leben ihres Vaters
des deutschen Staatsbürgers jamiede
schau mal macht
und einen Angriffskrieg seinen
Nachbarland überfallen es zerstören und
dort schwerste Kriegsverbrechen begehen
und dann trotzdem an Olympischen Spielen
teilnehmen dem Fest der Völker und des
Friedens für die Ukraine ist es
undenkbar dass ihre Athleten gegen
Russen antreten sollen als gäbe es
diesen Krieg nicht auf einer eigenen
Webseite erinnert das ukrainische
sportkomitee an die vielen Athleten und
Trainer die diesen Krieg bereits zum
Opfer fielen wie zum Beispiel der Jugend
Europameister im Boxen Maxim
gallinischeff auf ihm lagen große
sportliche Hoffnung vor knapp drei
Wochen starb er mit gerade mal 22 Jahren
an der frontin
vor diesem Hintergrund haben viele
Sportverbände das Internationale
Olympische Komitee aufgefordert
russische und belarussische Athleten
nicht wieder zu internationalen
Wettbewerben zuzulassen doch das IOC hat
anders entschieden berichtet Heike
Schulz
Skulpturen vor dem olympiamuseum in
Lusan kein Schuss soll fallen im
olympischen Sport Einzelteile der
olympischen Welt sich harmonisch zu
einem Ganzen Formen doch der
Angriffskrieg von Russland gegen die
Ukraine geht weiter heute hat das IOC
empfohlen Sportler aus Russland und
Belarus als neutral Athleten wieder
zuzulassen und beruft sich auf die
un-sonderberichterstatterin für
kulturelle Rechte
visuis die Frage ist wie gehen wir mit
Einzelperson um im Gegensatz zu
Mannschaften
es ist keine Grauzone des
internationalen Rechts
alle Staaten und Individuen
sogar so wichtig dass wir es als
zwingende Norm des Völkerrechts
bezeichnen
aus diesem Grund kann das pauschale
Verbot russischer und belarussischer
Sportler nicht aufrecht erhalten werden
das wäre ein eklatanter Verstoß gegen
die Menschenrechte auf Human Rights
Sportsoldaten Athleten die den
russischen Angriffskrieg unterstützen
sind ausgeschlossen aber das reicht
vielen nicht ich bin sehr enttäuscht
weil ich finde die Entscheidung des IOCs
ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht aller
ukrainischen Sportlerinnen Sportler die
Athletinnen Athleten haben mühsam
Unterkunft in anderen Ländern gefunden
um an internationalen
Großveranstaltungen stattfinden und das
jetzt diejenigen Sportler aus Russland
die den Angriffskrieg gegen Putin führen
zu internationalen Sportereignissen
zugelassen werden sollen wieder empfinde
ich als falsche Entscheidung mehr als
300 Fechterinnen aus aller Welt bieten
dem EOC die Stirn sprechen sich gegen
eine Rückkehr von Russen und Belarussen
aus Russlands Aggression verstößt nicht
nur gegen die Normen des Völkerrechts
sondern auch gegen die grundlegenden
Werte des olympiasmus darunter Frieden
Völkerverständigung die Achtung der
Menschenwürde und der Menschenrechte
thomas Bach bleibt mit seinem IOC auf
dem Kurs den er schon im Januar im
Winter im Oberhof angedeutet hatte mit
seinen Einschränkungen wenn Russen und
Belarussen vermehrt auf die Weltbühne
des Sports zurückkehren das heißt keine
Flagge keine Hymne keine Uniformen keine
Regierungsvertreter dieser beiden
Nationen auf den Tribünen die
folgenschildert die deutsche Florett
Europameisterin Leonie Ebert gerade von
einem Weltcup wieder zu Hause
beschlossen dass sie an keinen Wettkampf
teilnehmen werden an dem russischen
teilnehmen ein Jahr vor den Spielen in
Paris stellt die Russland Akte den
weltsportverein die Lämmer wie vereint
man Kriegsparteien im Sport es drohen
wollt konnte als Zerreißprobe
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter eine lange diskutierte
EU-Regelung die erreichen soll das ab
20035 Neuwagen emissionsfrei unterwegs
sind ist heute von der Mitgliedstaaten
beschlossen worden dazu gehört auch das
Autos mit Verbrennungsmotor weiter neu
zugelassen werden können wenn sie
ausschließlich mit klimaneutralen
synthetischen Kraftstoffen fahren mit
sogenannten e-fues und diese e-fuels
Lösung hatte es ja politisch einigen
Wirbel gegeben Frank beetmann welche
Dimension hat es wirtschaftlich ja das
ist heute noch nicht absehbar
Verkehrsminister Wissing wollte eine
Alternative zu Elektroautos auch nach
2035 Verbrenner Neuwagen wenn sie denn
jetzt mit ifuels betankt werden können
auch dann noch zugelassen werden doch ob
das überhaupt in relevanter Zahl
passieren wird ist mehr als fraglich
denn bislang werden die für uns nur in
Pilotanlagen hergestellt dabei wird mit
Hilfe von klimaneutralen Strom aus
Wasserstoff und Kohlendioxid dieser
Treibstoff erzeugt und auch wenn eine
solche Produktion nun in Windeseile
hochgefahren würde heißt es unter
anderem vom Potsdamer Institut für
Klimafolgenforschung das nach 2035 nicht
einmal ansatzweise genug e-fuels
weltweit produziert werden um den Bedarf
allein für deutsche Verbrenner zu decken
das ist der Punkt der Mengen was ist
dann noch in der Diskussion naja selbst
die größten Befürworter von efuels geben
zu mit den Preisen von fossilen
Kraftstoffen können diese künstliche
hergestellten nicht mithalten wir reden
also über einen aktuell sehr teuren
Treibstoff der zudem in der Herstellung
sehr Energie spricht Strom intensiv ist
und auch wichtig wenn schon als dann so
die Kritiker doch bitte vor allem in der
Schiff und Luftfahrt einsetzen dort
kommt man nämlich mit Batterien oder
Elektromotoren nicht weit von daher wäre
dort die Verwendung von uns sehr viel
sinnvoller als bei Autos
vielen Dank
und zur Elektro Mobilität in der EU soll
es entlang der wichtigsten
Verkehrsachsen in den kommenden Jahren
mindestens alle 60 km Ladesäulen geben
darauf haben sich Vertreter des
EU-Parlaments und der Mitgliedstaaten
geeinigt außerdem soll es bis 2031
mindestens alle 200 km
Wasserstofftankstellen geben
eine russische sajus-kapsel die
eigentlich von der Raumstation ISS 3
Besatzungsmitglieder zurück auf die Erde
bringen sollte ist heute unbemannt in
der kasachischen Steppe gelandet
planmäßig und sicher wie die russische
Raumfahrtbehörde mitteilte die Kapsel
war von einem meteorteilchen beschädigt
worden ein Leck machte die Rückkehr der
Raumfahrer unmöglich sie sollen im
September per ersatzkapsel von der ISS
zurückgeholt werden
das war's von uns mit der Reportage
Reihe 37 Grad geht es gleich weiter
heute unter dem Titel Lebenslügen und
Familiengeheimnisse und um 0 Uhr meldet
sich dann Christopher Beermann mit
unserem Update und wir morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend nach dem kleinen hoch
liliosa übernimmt jetzt das tiefe lasse
das Wetter geschehen bei uns in
Mitteleuropa das bedeutet es wird
deutlich milder auch deutlich
regnerischer und zum Schluss auch viel
stürmischer heute Nacht gibt es schon
Regen und zum Teil noch letzte
schneeregenfälle hier im Nordwesten aber
auch im Südwesten im Osten ist es
dagegen meist trocken und auch klar und
dort sinken die Temperaturen bis -4 Grad
im Westen macht sich schon diese mildere
Luft merkbar da liegen die
Tiefsttemperaturen bei 6 bis 1 Grad und
so geht der Schneeregen mehr und mehr in
Regen über im Laufe der Nacht morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen in
Vorpommern in der Lausitzen auch im
Nordfriesland bei einstelligen acht oder
neun Grad sonst werden zweistellige
Temperaturen erreicht und am Rhein am
Neckar und an der Mose wird es
frühlingshaft Milch mit 15 bis 18 Grad
die Sonne werden sie morgen hier in der
Nordosthälfte kaum zu Gesicht bekommen
und vor allen Dingen am Vormittag kann
es an der Küste noch leicht regnen im
Südwesten ist es freundlicher allerdings
ziehen dort einige kleine Regenschauer
durch bei Südwestwind der Donnerstag
wird dann sehr wechselhaft mit Schauern
und Gewittern am Freitag wird es in
Südwesten stürmisch und am Samstag wird
es deutlich kälter zumindest an der
Ostsee da dreht der Wind nämlich auf
nordöstliche Richtung jetzt schauen wir
uns mal an die genau im Nordosten
nämlich hier in Schwerin die Karwoche
dann weitergeht sie sehen da liegen die
Temperaturen Meister zwischen 6 und 11
Grad